belfast birmingham
brighton ennis skillin
shankel grey steel three and a half
thousand people were murdered during the
troubles
kathleen's husband patsy was one of them
the people who murdered my husband
are still walking free and they're
unlikely to ever face prosecution
with the government proposing a de facto
amnesty it is clear that the current
system
for dealing with the legacy of the
troubles is not working
it is now a difficult in fact a painful
truth that the focus on criminal
investigations
is increasingly unlikely to deliver
successful criminal justice outcomes
there will be no justice for kathleen's
husband patsy
who died when the ira chained him to a
van containing a bomb
and forced him to drive it into a
military base well i feel robbed
i feel robbed of the whole thing because
i just feel that uh
have this thing in my head that when
it's um
an an important person that's been
killed they're
things investigated and their things
solved and all the rest of it and
we're just the ordinary common people so
it's all right
they push us to the one side julie
hamilton's sister maxine was killed in
the birmingham pub bombings
the labour leader raised her case with
boris johnson she says
tell me prime minister if one of your
loved ones was blown up
beyond recognition where you were only
able to identify your son or daughter by
their fingernails
would you be so quick to grant their
murderers
an amnesty nothing i sale or can do now
can in any way mitigate her her loss
this
legislation is basically
writing off any history that our loved
ones
ever existed
the government's honoring a manifesto
pledge to end what it calls
the witch hunt against veterans
devastating for the families of those
shot dead by paratroopers on bloody
sunday in londonderry
this is all just to protect soldiers to
protect our boys
and i don't trust the british government
why not well would you trust them if
they murdered your brother and told
elizabeth
they were never hopeful of justice but
victims on all sides are equally
skeptical
about the truth recovery process
bringing any end to their suffering
david blevins sky news in derry